hello and welcome to this video playing
paranoid I'm going to take your pawn
down yeah yeah experimental agenda
Queens gambit accepted oh that's a very
early cuneiform hmm now I have six now
dis transpose to that to that to the
normal way of playing this check I just
wonder if I have some other other
opportunity here this early Queen moves
might be interesting to try stuff night
at six is normal we should reform maybe
just putting more pressure there I don't
know interesting yeah well yeah I'm am I
not just winning material here 2496 27
well it's not the greatest greatest porn
ever okay LF Bishop g7 of course Bishop
d7
okay i'm going to take the pawn I mean
it is really not the greatest pond but
still Quincy 426 this is the pond I can
also take it with a bit upon that's me
maybe this is more interesting to win
tempe on the queen but ok i'm going to
go into trade queens there i'm not sure
as i said it's not the greatest porn
ever but janet is one so much developed
stuff it is probably not not not really
great for black to be honest if he goes
f3e for and just develop just develop
freely that's completely fine how would
you do that maybe something g6 based no
g6 ah age 6 it was a mouse lib age six
are ridiculous ah my goodness that hurts
I move hurts in this position it really
does okay after I have to do it
differently then play with e6e 605
Bishop a 6 h-6 and this is the kind of
mouse loop that lets your opponent think
you are completed yet h6
I mean we should be six pots played with
intention of playing g6 Bishop g7 and
possibly like 95 and 97 ok this is still
seems kind of okay at least I'm not I'm
not seeing anything I'm terrible
happening to me 97 here on just just
more development yeah maybe just develop
stuff he's got 94 okay well then 97
maybe 97 you might double I can do this
here actually that's not so bad
yeah that's okay a position is
reasonably coordinated him
you
ok
well may I can I'm not not going to just
win with the porn i guess i mean it's
not happening i don't think i'm
reasonably solid him his bishops don't
have that great scope
I'm sure oh I didn't expect him to trade
stuff I'm happy to okay happy to oblige
them and now he had worked the 80 I mean
okay not not exactly not it would really
have huge hopes you have your chops to
to win it or so it may be maybe there
are some ideas now 83 I wonder if this
is this is a movie this is just nonsense
a three here okay it's maybe maybe it's
a bit a bit too ambitious but we'll see
b 3 i'm going c4 after tix i can go look
a 4 actually that's an interesting move
well I plant 90-84 but look a four is
interesting it's probably more
interesting also then the night capture
check I Scott shatters no that isn't
great right it isn't really great I
really need to get in rupee 8b five and
capture that it's the only but maybe I
can do that Jade's looks questionable do
some time morning
okay getting the seaport at least book
t5 is a good move maybe four mook takes
a far walk c5 check ok after can
something going here to do that check
check check check check okay how are you
poorness doing stuff it's not so bad
well it's a draw i think i have no time
right okay stalemate okay I'm doing that
I'm not sure what what happened damn
maybe I can I do stuff I don't know I
guess by rookie to we can sing with me
anyway okay tough tough game tough game
don't know don't know I mean age 6
what's one of the more ridiculous mouth
lips yeah of course the AG six was the
plan and no age 6 yeah when I think I
think I did reasonably well after it I
think bishop CA it was a good decision
just switch switch gears and now get
offended like that then that feel that
helps kind of okay this and now I could
have played H at age four year a form
and a three whoops that would have been
a lot better and and this is very nice
for black really oh nah didn't see that
at all
nice yeah okay I had this this kind of
discipline set up in mind that that
holds video pretty comfortably I felt
but didn't didn't really see that other
I share and check and here I Felton I'm
under some pressure but probably okay
yes Jan Mike I should check now you
should check now this is a bit risky
giving him the eight ball and check and
I'm not really sure I boss played with
very little time check check no I get
from hit the engine is on and 000
probably because my e porn is quite
dangerous and he can always escape if
you want to call it like that into that
stalemate yeah probably relatively Pedro
I could have played a four and three
that would have been much better okay
thanks for watching